compact SUVs have become the vehicle of
choice for millions of drivers one
reason Honda's HRV is already heading
into its second generation car testet
Anshu Ghent wants to see what it's got
that other sub compact SUVs haven't
that's why he knows that many might
think this is Honda's first crossover
SUV but in fact they introduced one back
in 1999 that soon disappeared
no Honda is building on the chance in an
effort to establish the HRV in the
crossover segment it's in costal was it
meant so it's helped me of them the
Front's back sweeping headlights and
sporty fascia are the latest examples of
Honda's new trademark look the body
borrows heavily from Kupe designs while
rear door handles hidden in the seat
filler reinforced the dynamic aesthetic
in back quirky LED tail lights command
attention rather sneaky off the phone
Ganju assures anyone who has doubts
about space in the back of the HRV that
he's sitting comfortably but he can
imagine that anyone over a meter 85
might feel wedged in the fuel tank isn't
built in under the backseat like in most
cars she says but under the front seats
one advantage of that is I'm fourth I
list it leaves enough space for what
Honda calls magic seats - oh no -
explains the magic seats fold up to
accommodate bulky items that would
otherwise be difficult to transport for
example potted plants this is a much
more convenient way to carry this kind
of load he says meet somebody flunking
those epic fail on 14 but a disadvantage
is that if you'd like to relax during a
long trip you'll quickly discover the
limitations of placing the fuel tank
there but taunt you could live with that
tank
I wish stinky dust Acosta
overall the HRVs interior leaves a
respectable impression alongside the
touchscreen display it features a touch
based automatic climate control the econ
mode helps save fuel by slightly
altering throttle and transmission
response
[Music]
it's activated by a button bearing a
plant icon on the dash
[Music]
the Ikhwan d'Anjou emphasizes that the
econ mode is a clever way to save fuel
even when switched off the green LED
indicator reminds the driver to plan
ahead it also makes the cruise control
more reluctant to hit the gas while
cruise control usually apply 75% of
acceleration to maintaining speed an
econ mode it feels more like 25% less
potent Acuff in other words an econ mode
it can take the cruise control up to 30
seconds to accelerate from 100
kilometers an hour to 120 we tested the
HRVs diesel version with a 1.6 liter id
tech engine even with relatively low co2
emissions of just 104 grams per
kilometer and fuel efficient operation
the compact SUV makes no compromises on
performance with 88 kilowatts carrying
it from 0 to 100 km/h in 10 seconds
honda rates fuel consumption at 4 liters
per 100 kilometers and germany the HRV
starts in just under 24,000 euros the
thick mint owns you points out that the
market for crossovers is huge with every
car maker competing for a slice of the
pie he thinks the HRV is a very
substantial vehicle the diesel in his
test car had plenty of pep and efficient
besides he personally liked the touch
sensitive controls and the panoramic
roof of all this history is that sure
but does the HRV have what it takes to
compete in the hard-fought sector
saundra doubts the model will disappear
in the next few years to the contrary he
foresees a gaining a foothold in the
market
you